- When counting by 5s starting from 179,
When counting by 5s starting from 179,
which numbers will you say?
So, let's do that.
Let's start with 179,
and let's count by 5s.
So, 179 + 5 is equal to what.
Well, 179.
One way I think about it, 179 + 5
is the same thing as 179 + 1 + 4,
and I've added 1 just so I get to 180.
So, this part right here is equal to 180,
so it's gonna be the
same thing as 180 + 4,
so it's equal to 184.
Now, let's keep going.
So, we start at 179, then we go to 184.
Then if we want to add 5 to that,
well, 184 + 5, we add 5 in the ones place,
we get 189.
Now, if we add 5 again,
we're gonna do just what we had over here.
189 + 5,
that's the same thing as 189 + 1 + 4.
189 + 1 is 190, plus 4 is 194.
So, this is gonna be 194.
And then, if you add 5,
you're going to get 199.
I just added the 5 to this
4 here in the ones place.
Now, if you add 5 again.
This would be 199 + 5 is the
same thing as 199 + 1 + 4.
So, 199 + 1 is 200, plus 4 is 204.
So, let's see which of
these numbers we see so far.
So, we saw 184.
We see 189.
We didn't see 186.
We saw 194.
We saw 199.
and we saw 204.
And we are done.